what we're going to do in this video is
review the product rule that you
probably learned a while ago and from
that we're going to derive the formula
for integration by parts which could
really be viewed as the inverse product
rule integration by parts so let's say
that i start with some function that can
be expressed as the product f of x can
be expressed as a product of two other
functions f of x times g of x
now let's take the derivative of this of
this function let's apply the derivative
operator right over here and this once
again just review of the product rule
it's going to be the derivative of the
first function times the second function
so it's going to be f now i want to do
that blue color
it's going to be
f that's not blue
it's going to be
f prime of x times g of x
times that's not the same color
times g of x
g of x
plus
plus
the first function times the derivative
of the second
plus the first function f of x times the
derivative of the second derivative
of the second this is all review right
over here derivative of the first time
the second function plus the first
function times the derivative of the
second function
now let's take the antiderivative of
both sides of this equation well if i
take the antiderivative of what i have
here on the left i get
f of x times g of x
times g of x we won't think about the
the constant for now we can ignore that
for now and that's going to be equal to
well what's the anti-derivative of this
this is going to be the antiderivative
of f prime of x f prime of x times g of
x
times g of x dx
dx
plus the antiderivative of f of x
f of x g prime of x g prime of x dx
now what i want to do is solve i am
going to solve for this part right over
here and to solve for that
i just have to subtract this business i
just have to subtract this business from
both sides and then i am left with i'm
left if i subtract that from both sides
i'm left with f of x
times g of x
times g of x minus this
minus
the antiderivative of
f prime of x
g of x
g and let me do that pink color
g of x
g of x dx
dx is equal to what i wanted to solve
for is equal to the anti-derivative of f
of x
g prime of x
g prime of x
dx
dx and to make it a little bit clearer
let me swap sides here so let me copy
and paste this so let me copy
and then paste it
there you go and then let me copy and
paste the other side so let me
copy
and paste it so i'm just switching the
size just to give it in a form that you
might be that you might be more used to
seeing in a calculus book
so this tells us this is essentially the
formula for integration by parts i will
square it off
you'll often see it squared off in a
traditional textbook so i will do the
same
so this right over here tells us that if
we have an integral or an antiderivative
of the form
f of x times the derivative of some
other function we can apply this right
over here and you might say well this
doesn't seem that useful first i have to
identify a
function that's like this and then it's
still i have an integral in it but what
we will see in the next video is that
this can actually simplify a whole bunch
of
things that you're trying to take the
anti-derivative of